hi guys
welcome to this docker full course by
simply learn
in this full course video we will be
covering all the important topics
related to the devops tool docker that
you need to know
we will begin by watching a short
animated video on what is devoxx
followed by understanding what docker is
and then
we will look at how to install docker on
ubuntu
going further we will study the docker
concepts in detail
and then look at docker container docker
swarm
and docker compose finally we have
compiled the most important docker
interview questions
that you might face in a docker or
devops interview
so without further ado let us get
started
hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to cover
what is docker and why it should be of
value to you
as somebody who works in devops so
let's take a little scenario of a
developer and a tester
before you had the world of docker
a developer would actually build their
code and then they send it
to the tester but then the code wouldn't
work on their system
the code doesn't work on the other
system due to the differences in
computer
environments so what could be the
solution to this
well you could go ahead and create a
virtual machine to be the same
of the solution in both areas we think
docker
is an even better solution so let's kind
of break out
what the main big differences are
between docker and virtual machines
as you can see between the left and the
right hand side both
look to be very similar what you'll see
however
is that on the docker side what you'll
see as a big difference
is that the guest os for each container
has been eliminated docker is inherently
more lightweight but provides the same
functionality
as a virtual machine so let's step
through some of the
pros and cons of a virtual machine
versus docker
so first of all a virtual machine
occupies a lot more
memory space on the host machine
in contrast docker occupies
significantly
less memory space the boot up time
between both
is very different docker just boots up
faster the performance of the docker
environment
is actually better and more consistent
than the virtual machine
docker is also very easy to set up
and very easy to scale the efficiencies
therefore
are much higher with a docker
environment versus a virtual machine
environment
and you'll find it is easier to port
docker
across multiple platforms than a virtual
machine
finally the space allocation between
docker and
a virtual machine is significant when
you don't have to include the guest os
you're eliminating a significant amount
of space
and the docker environment is just
inherently smaller
so after docker as a developer you can
build out your solution
and send it to a tester and as long as
we're all running in the docker
environment
everything will work just great so let's
step through what we're going to cover
in this presentation
we're going to look at the devops tools
and where docker fits within that space
we'll examine what docker actually is
and how docker works
and then finally we'll step through the
different components
of the docker environment so what is
devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development team the operation team
allowing you to continuously deliver
solutions and applications and services
that both delight and improve the
efficiency of your customers
if you look at the venn diagram that we
have here on the
left hand side we have development on
the right hand side we have operation
and then there's a crossover
in the middle and that's where the
devops team sits
if we look at the areas of integration
between both groups
developers are really interested in
planning code
building and testing and operations want
to be able to efficiently deploy
operate a monitor when you can have both
groups
interacting with each other on these
seven
key and elements then you can have the
efficiencies of an
excellent devops team so planning and
code base we use tools like jit
and geara for building we use gradle and
maven testing we use selenium
the integration between dev and ops is
through tools such as jenkins
and then the deployment operation is
done with tools such as docker and chef
finally nagios is used to monitor
the entire environment so let's step
deeper
into what docker actually is so docker
is a tool which is used to automate the
deployment of applications
in a lightweight container so the
application can work
efficiently in different environments
now it's important to note the container
is actually a software package that
consists of all the dependencies
required to run the application so
multiple containers can run on the same
hardware
the containers are maintained in
isolated environments
they're highly productive and they're
quick and easy to configure
so let's take an example of what docker
is by using
a house that may be rented for someone
using airbnb
so in the house there are three rooms
and only one cupboard and kitchen
and the problem we have is that none of
the guests are really ready to share the
cupboard and kitchen
because every individual has a different
preference when it comes to
how the cupboard should be stocked and
how the kitchen should be used
this is very similar to how we run
software applications today
each of the applications could end up
using different
frameworks so you may have a framework
such as
rails perfect and flask and
you may want to have them running for
different applications for different
situations this is where docker will
help you run the applications
with the suitable frameworks so let's go
back to our airbnb
example so we have three rooms and a
kitchen and cupboard
how do we resolve this issue well we put
a kitchen and cupboard in each room
we can do the same thing for computers
docker provides the suitable frameworks
for each different application and since
every application has a framework with a
suitable version this space can also
then be utilized
for putting in software and applications
that are long
and since every application has its own
framework and suitable version
the area that we had previously stored
for a framework can be used for
something else
now we can create a new application in
this instance a fourth application that
uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder docker is the right choice
so let's take a closer look to how
docker actually works
so when we look at docker and we call
something docker we're actually
referring to the base engine which
actually is installed on the host
machine
that has all the different components
that run your docker environment
and if we look at the image on the left
hand side of the screen you'll see that
docker has a client
server relationship there's a client
installed on the
hardware there is a client that contains
the docker
product and then there is a server which
controls how that docker client
is created the communication that goes
back and forth to be able to
share the knowledge on that docker
client relationship is done through a
rest api
and this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that api
so we look here in the animation we see
that the docker client is
constantly communicating back to the
server information
about the infrastructure and it's using
this rest api
as that communication channel the docker
server then will check
out the requests and the interaction
necessary for it to be the docker daemon
which runs on the server itself will
then check out the interaction
and the necessary operating system
pieces needed to be able to run the
container
okay so that's just an overview of the
docker engine which is
probably where you're going to spend
most of your time but there are some
other components that form the
infrastructure for docker let's dig into
those a little bit deeper as well
so what we're going to do now is break
out the four main components that
comprise
of the docker environment the four
components
are as follows the docker client and
server which we've already done
a deeper dive on docker images docker
containers
and the docker registry so if we look
at the structure that we have here on
the left hand side you see the
relationship between the docker client
and the docker server and then we have
the rest
api in between now if we start digging
into that rest api particularly the
relationship
with the docker daemon on the server we
actually have
our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem
so the docker client is accessed from
your terminal window so
if you are using windows this can be
powershell on
mac it's going to be your terminal
window and it allows you to
run the docker daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open
so you can actually use your terminal
window to create
instructions on how to build and run
your docker images and containers
if we look at the images part of our
registry here we actually see that the
image is really just a template with the
instructions used for creating the
containers
which you use within docker the docker
image is built using a file called the
docker file
and then once you've created that docker
file you'll store that image
in the docker hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a docker
environment that you've created
the syntax of creating the image is
fairly simple
it's something that you'll be able to
get your arms around very quickly
and essentially what you're doing is
you're creating the
option of a new container you're
identifying
what the image will look like what are
the commands that are needed and the
arguments for within those commands and
once you've done that you have
a definition for what your image will
look like
so if we look here at what the container
itself
looks like is that the container is a
standalone
executable package which includes
applications and their dependencies it's
the instructions
for what your environment will look like
so you can be consistent
in how that environment is shared
between multiple developers
testing units and other people within
your devops team
now the thing that's great about working
with docker is that it's so
lightweight that you can actually run
multiple docker containers
in the same infrastructure and share the
same operating system
this is its strength it allows you to be
able to create those multiple
environments that you need
for multiple projects that you're
working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an
isolated area for the applications to
run
so while you can run multiple containers
in an infrastructure each of those
containers are completely isolated
they're protected
so that you can actually control how
your solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more
important and you start adding in more
people to your team
you may have 15 people that are offshore
you may have 10 people that are local
you may have
15 consultants that are working on your
project you have
a need for each of those developers or
each person on your team to have access
to that docker image and to get access
to that image we use the docker registry
which is an
open source server-side service for
hosting and distributing the images
that you have defined you can also use
docker itself as its own default
registry and docker hub
now something it has to be very mind
though is that for publicly shared
images you may want to have
your own private images in which case
you would do that through your own
registry so once again public
repositories can be used to
host the docker images which can be
accessed by anyone
and i really encourage you to go out to
docker and see the other
docker images that have been created
because there may be tools there that
you can use to speed up your own
development environments now you will
also get to a point where you
start creating environments that are
very specific
to the solutions that you are building
and when you get to that point you'll
likely want to create a private
repository
so you're not sharing that knowledge
with the world in general
now the way in which you connect with
the docker registry
is through simple pull and push commands
that you run through terminal window
to be able to get the latest information
so if you want to be able to build your
own container
what you'll start doing is using the
pull commands to actually pull
the image from the docker repository and
the command line for that is fairly
simple
in terminal window you would write
docker pull and then you put in the
image name and any tags associated with
that image
and use the command pulls so in your
terminal window you would actually use
a simple line of command once you've
actually connected to your docker
environment and that command will be
docker pull with the image name and any
associated tags around that image
what that will then do is pull the image
from the docker repository whether
that's a public repository or a private
one
now in reverse if you want to be able to
update
the docker image with a new information
you do a
push command where you would take the
script that you've written about the
docker container that you
defined and push it to the repository
and as you can imagine
the commands for that are also fairly
simple in terminal window you would
write docker
push the image name any associated tags
and then that would then
push that image to the docker repository
again
either a public or a private repository
so if we recap
the docker file creates a docker image
that's using the build commands
a docker image then contains all the
information necessary for you to be able
to execute the project
using the docker image any user can run
the code in order to create
a docker container and once a docker
image is built it's uploaded to a
registry or to a docker hub where it can
be shared across your entire team
and from the docker hub users can get
access to the docker image
and build their own new containers
welcome to all our viewers
i'm anjali from simply learn and today
i'll be taking you through the
installation process
for docker so before we begin let me
give you an
intro to docker so what is docker docker
is a tool which is used to automate the
deployment of
applications in lightweight containers
so when i say containers i mean a
software package that consists of all
the dependencies required to run the
particular application
and when you deploy containers you're
basically providing
the capability for the application to
run in
any kind of environment so dockers have
multiple features
some of which are that multiple
containers can run on the same hardware
it has very high productivity when
compared to virtual machines
it maintains isolated applications and
has a very quick
and easy configuration process so now
let's begin with the demo
we'll be installing docker on an ubuntu
system
so this is my system i'll just open the
terminal
so the first thing you can start with is
removing any docker installation that
you probably
already have present in your system if
you want to start from scratch
so this is the command to do so sudo apt
get remove
docker
docker engine docker dot io enter your
password
and docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install docker
once again
before that i'll just clear my screen
okay so before i install docker let me
just ensure that all the softwares on my
system currently
is in its latest state so sudo apt
get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually
install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment
of the machine that you're working in
this particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install
docker dot io
is a command that we will need to
execute to install docker
and after that we will execute the suru
snap install docker
so sudo apt install docker dot io first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have sudo snap
install docker
so snap install docker installs a newly
created snap package
there are basically some other
dependencies for docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire docker i o
it will take some time
great so our docker is installed the
next thing we do as i mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that
is
sudo snap install docker
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for docker
but we'll perform a few more stages
where we will test if the installation
has been done right
so before we move on with the testing
for docker
let's once again just check the version
that we have installed
so for that the command is docker
version and as you can see docker
version 17.12.1
ce has been installed next thing we do
is we pull an image from the docker hub
so docker run hello
world now hello world is a docker image
which is present on the docker hub
docker hub is basically a repository
that you can find online so with this
command the docker image hello world has
been pulled onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now
the command to check this is sudo
docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository
this is present on our system currently
so the image has been successfully
pulled onto the system
and this means that our docker is
working now we'll try out
another command
sudo docker ps minus a this displays
all the containers that you have pulled
so far so as you can see here there are
three hello world images displayed
and all of them are in exited state so i
did this demo
previously too which is why the two
hello worlds which
is created two minutes ago is also
displayed here
and the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago
is the one we just did for this demo now
as you
have probably noticed that all the hello
world images
over here all these containers are in
the exited state
so when you give the option for docker
ps minus a
where minus a stands for all it displays
all the containers whether they are in
exited or running state
if you want to see only those containers
which are
in their running state you can simply
execute
sudo docker ps
suro docker yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them
are in running state and with that we
come to an
end of our docker installation this is
matthew from simply learn and today
we're going to dig
through what docker is and how you could
be using it within your own devops
environment so let's get started
in this presentation we're going to go
through a number of key things we're
going to compare
docker versus traditional virtual
machines and what are the differences
and why you want to choose docker over a
virtual environment
we'll go through the advantages of
working with docker and the structure
and how you would build out a docker
environment and during that structure
we'll
dig through the components and the
advanced components within docker
at the end of the presentation we'll go
through some basic commands and then
show you how those basic commands can be
used in a live
demo so with all that said let's get
started
so let's first of all compare docker
with a traditional virtual machine so
here we have the architecture on the
left and right
of a traditional virtual machine versus
a darker environment
and there are some things that you'll
probably see immediately that are
big differences one is that the virtual
environment has
hypervisor layer whereas the docker
environment has a docker engine layer
and then in addition to that there are
additional layers
within the virtual machine each of these
really start compounding and creating
very significant differences between
a docker environment and a virtual
machine environment so
with a virtual machine the actual memory
usage is very high whereas
with the docker environment the memory
usage is very low
if we look at performance virtual
machines when you start
building out particularly more than one
virtual machine on
a server the performance starts
degrading and starts getting
poorer whereas with docker the
performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture
used to construct the docker containers
themselves
if we look at portability virtual
machines just are terrible for
portability they're still dependent on
the host operating system
and there's just a lot of problems that
happen when you are
using virtual machines for portability
in contrast docker was designed for
portability
so you can actually build solutions in a
docker container environment and
have the guarantee that the solution
will work as you
have built it no matter where it's
hosted finally boot up time now the bit
up time for
a virtual machine is fairly slow in
comparison
to the boot up time for a docker
environment which is almost
instantaneous
so we look at these in a little bit more
detail one of the other challenges that
you have
with a virtual machine is that if you
have
unused memory within the environment
you cannot reallocate that memory so if
you set up an environment that has
nine gigs of memory that's being used
but you have six gigs that are free
you can't do anything with it though
that whole nine gig has been allocated
to that virtual machine
in contrast with docker if you have nine
gigs and six gigs becomes free
that free memory can then be reallocated
and reused across
other containers used within that docker
environment
another challenge is running multiple
virtual machines
in a single environment that can lead to
instability and performance issues
whereas
docker is designed to run multiple
containers
in the same environment and actually
gets better the more
containers you run in that hosted single
docker engine
portability issues with a virtual
machine
is the software can work on one machine
but then when you move
that vm to another machine suddenly some
of the software won't work because there
are some dependencies that haven't been
inherited correctly
whereas docker itself is designed
specifically
to be able to run across multiple
environments and
to be deployed very easily across the
systems
and again the actual boot up time for a
vm it just
takes a long time you took about minutes
in contrast
to the milliseconds that it takes for a
docker environment to boot up
so let's dig into what docker actually
is and what allows for these
great performance improvements over a
traditional vm environment
so docker itself is an os virtualized
software platform and it allows it
organizations to really
easily create deploy and run
applications as what
are called docker containers that have
all the dependencies within that
container
very easily and the container itself is
really just a very lightweight package
that has all the instructions and
dependencies such as frameworks
libraries bins etc
all within that container and that
container itself can then be moved from
environment to environment
very easily if we to look in our devops
life cycle the place where docker really
shines
is in deployment because when you're
actually at the point of deploying your
solution you want to be able to
guarantee that the code that has been
tested will actually work in the
production environment but in addition
to that
what we often find is that when you're
actually building the code and you're
actually testing the code
having a container running the solution
at those stages
is also a really good plus because what
happens is that the people building the
code and testing the code
are able to validate their work in the
same environment that would be used for
the production environment so
really you can use docker in multiple
stages within your devops cycle
but it becomes really valuable in the
deployment stage
so let's look at some of the key
advantages that you have with docker
some things that we've already covered
is that you can do
rapid deployment and you can do it
really fast the environment itself
is highly portable and was designed for
that in mind
the efficiencies that you'll see will
allow you to run multiple docker
containers in a single environment
as compared to more traditional vm
environments
the configuration itself can be scripted
through a language called yaml which
allows you to be able to
write out and describe the docker
environment that you want to create
this in turn allows you to be able to
scale your environment very very quickly
but with all of these advantages
probably the one that is most critical
to the type of work that we're doing
today
is security you have to ensure that the
environment you are running is a highly
secure
but highly scalable environment and i'm
very pleased to say that docker takes
security very seriously
so you'll see it as one of the key
talents for the actual
architecture of the system that you're
implementing so let's look at how docker
actually works within
your environment so docker works there
is a
what's called a docker engine the docker
engine is really comprised
of two key elements so you have a server
and a client and the communication via
the two
is via a rest api the server as you can
imagine
has the instructions that are
communicated out to the client and
instructs the client on what to do the
connection between
the client and the server the
communication is via
a rest api on older systems you can take
advantage of the docker toolbox which
allows you to
go ahead and control the docker engine
the docker machine
docker compose and kitematic so let's
now go into what the actual
root components though of docker are so
let's have a look at those key
components
there are four components that we're
going to go through we have the docker
client and server
we have docker images we have the docker
registry and the docker container we're
going to step through each of these one
by one
so let's look at the docker clients and
server first
so the docker client and server is a
command line
instructed solution where you would use
terminal on your mac
or command line on your pc or linux
system to be able to issue commands from
the docker daemon
the communication between the docker
client and the docker host and
is via a rest api so
you can do sim communication such as a
docker pull command
which would send an instruction to the
daemon which would then
form the interaction of pulling in the
correct components
such as an image or container or
registry to the docker client
the docker daemon itself is actually a
service which actually performs all
sorts of operating and performance
services and as you'd imagine the docker
daemon is
constantly listing across the rest api
to see if it needs to perform any
specific requests
if you want to trigger and start the
whole process you what you want to do is
use the command
dockered within your docker daemon and
that will start
all of your performances and then you
have a docker host which actually runs
the docker daemon and
registry itself so now let's look into
the actual structure of
a docker image so a docker image itself
is a template which contains
instructions
for the docket container and that
template is written with a language
called yaml and yaml
stands for yet another markup language
it's very easy to learn
the docker image itself is built within
that
yaml file and then host it as a file
in the docket registry the image
is really comprised of several key
layers
and you start with your base layer which
will typically have
your base image and this instance is
your base operating system such as
ubuntu
and then you then have layer of
dependencies above that
this would then comprise the
instructions in a read-only
file that would become your docker file
so let's let you go through
and look at what one of those in sets of
instructions would look like
so here we have four layers of
instructions we have a from
pull run and then command so what does
that actually
look like in our layers so to break this
down
the from creates a layer which is based
on ubuntu
and then what we're doing is we're
adding in files from the docker
repository
onto that base command that base
layer and then what we want to be able
to do is then say okay
what are the wrong commands so we can
actually then build the container
within the environment and then we want
to be able to then have a command line
that actually
executes something within that container
and in this instance the command
is to run python so one of the things
that we will see is that as we set up
multiple containers each new container
is a
new layer with new images within the
docker environment
each container is completely separate
from the other containers within your
darker environment
so you're able to create your own
separate read write instructions
within each layer what's interesting is
that if you delete a layer then the
layer above it will also get deleted so
what happens when you pull in a layer
but something has changed in the
the core image what's interesting then
is that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've
copied the image you can then modify it
locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself so
here are some
callouts for the components within a
docket image so the base layer
are in read-only format the layers can
be combined in a union file system
to create a single image the union file
system saves memory space by avoiding
duplication of files and this allows a
file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy
on write the actual base layers
themselves are read only
so to be able to get around this
structure within a docker container
the docker environment itself uses
what's known as a copy and write
strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment
the copy and write strategy does make
docker super efficient
and what you're able to do all the time
is keep reducing
the amount of disk space you're using
and the amount of performance that
you're taking from the server and that's
really again a key
element for docker is just this constant
ability to be able to
keep improving the efficiency within the
actual system itself
all right so let's go on to item number
three which is the docker registry
so the docker registry itself is the
place where you would host and
distribute
the different types of images that you
have created or you want to be used
within your
environment the actual repository itself
is just
a collection of docker images and those
docker images
are built on instructions that you would
write with yaml and are very
easily stored and shared and what you
can actually do is you can actually
associate
specific name tags to the actual docker
images themselves so it's easy for
people to be able to find and share that
image within the docker registry itself
one of the things you actually see as we
go through the demos you actually see us
actually using the the tag name and
you'll see how
it is an alphanumeric identifier and how
we actually use it
to actually create the actual container
itself
one of the things you can do to as start
off how you would manage a registry is
you can actually use the
publicly accessible docker hub registry
which is available to
anybody but you can also create your own
registry for
your own use internally the actual
registry that you create internally can
have both public
and private images that you create and
this may be for various reasons of how
you structure
your environment the actual commands you
would use to actually
connect to the registry are both push
and pull push
is to actually push a new container
environment that you've created from
your local manager node to the remote
registry
and a pool allows you to pull a new
client that has been created and is
being shared
so again full command and it pulls and
retrieves
a docket image from the docker registry
and makes it very easy for people to
share different images consistently
across teams
and a push command allows you to take a
new command that you've created a new
container that you created and push it
to the registry whether it's docker hub
or whether it's your own private
registry and allow it to be shared
across your teams
some key did you know in docker registry
deleting a repository is not a
reversible
action so if you delete a repository
it's gone
so let's go into the final stage here
which is the actual docker container
itself
so the docker container itself um is an
executable package
of applications and its dependencies
bundled together so
it gives all the instructions that you
would have for
the solution that you're looking to run
it's actually
really lightweight and again this is
because of the redundancy that's built
into how
you structure the container and the
container itself is then
inherently also extremely portable
what's really good about running a
container though is that it does run
completely
in isolation so you're able to share it
very easily from grouped group and you
are guaranteed that
even if you are running a container it's
not going to be
impacted by any host os peculiarities
or unique setups as you would have in a
vm
or a non-containerized environment the
actual memory that you have
on a docker environment they can be
shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vm
you would have a defined amount of
memory for each vm
environment the change you start running
into though is that you can't share that
memory whereas with docker you can
easily share the memory
for a single environment across multiple
containers
the actual container is built using
docket images
and the commands to actually run those
images is a run command
all right so let's actually go through a
basic structure of how you would
run a docket image so you go into
terminal window and
you would write a docker run redis
and then it would run a container called
redis so we're going to go in and if you
don't have the redis image locally
installed it will then pull it from the
registry
then the new docker container redis will
be then available within
your environment so you can actually
start using it so let's
look at why containers are so
lightweight
they're so lightweight because they
really have been able to get away
from some of the additional layers that
you have in virtualization
within vms and the biggest one is the
hypervisor and the need to run on a host
operating system
those are two big big elements so if you
can get rid of those then you're doing
great
so let's look at some of the more
advanced concepts within
the docker environment and we're going
to look at two advanced components
one is docker compose and the second is
docker swamp
so let's look at docker compose docker
compose is really designed for running
multiple containers as a single service
and
it does this by running each container
in isolation but allowing the containers
to
interact with each other as was stated
earlier on
you would actually write the compose
environment using
yaml as the language in the files that
you would create
so where would you use something like
docker compose
so an example would be if you are
running an apache server with my sql
database
and you need to create additional
containers to run additional services
without the need to start each one
separately and this is where you would
write
a set of files using docker compose to
be able to help balance out
that demand so let's now look at docker
swarm
so docker swarm is a service that allows
you to be able to
control multiple docker environments
within a single platform so what you
actually
are looking at doing is within your
docker swamp is we're treating
each node as a docker daemon and we're
actually having an
api that's interacting with each of
those nodes
there are two types of node that you're
going to be getting comfortable working
with one is the manager node and the
second is the
worker node and as you'd expect the
manager node
is the one sending out the instructions
to all
of the worker nodes but there is a
two-way communication that is happening
the communication allows for the imagine
node to be able to manage the
instructions
and then listen to receive updates from
the working node so if anything happens
within this environment the imagine node
can react and
adjust the architecture of the worker
node
so it's always in sync it was really
great for
large scaled environments so finally
let's go through
what are some of the basic commands you
would use within docker
and once we've gone through all these
basic commands we'll actually show you a
demo of how you'd actually use them as
well
so if we're going to go in probably the
first command is to install
docker and so if you have yum installed
you just do yum install docker and
you'll install docker onto
your computer to start the docker daemon
as you want to do a system
ctl start docker the command to remove a
docker image is docker rmi
and then the image id itself and that's
not the image name that's the actual
alphanumeric id number that you want to
uh grab
the command line to download a new image
is docker pull
and then the name of the image you'd
want to pull and by default you're going
to be pulling
from the docker default registry that
will then
connect to your docker daemon and
download the images from
that registry client the command line to
run an image is docker run and then the
image id and then we have
the if we wanted to pull specifically
from docker hub
then we would have a docker pull and
then the image name and
colon its tag to pull build an image
from a docker file you would do
docker build t and then the image name
and
colon tag to shut down the container you
do
docker stop container id the access
for running a container is docker exec
it
container id bash so we've gone through
all the different commands but let's
actually see how they would actually
look and we're going to go ahead
and do a demo so welcome to this demo
where we're going to go ahead
and put together all of the different
commands that we have outlined in the
presentation for docker
uh first is just to list all of the
docker images that we have so we do
sudo docker images and we enter in our
password
and this will now list out the images
that we've created already
and we have three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a docker
image so to do that we'll
we'll go ahead and type sudo docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select
pull and then the name of the image that
we want to pull which is
going to be my sequel and by default
this is actually going to go ahead and
use the latest
my sequel command my sequel image that
we have so it's now gonna head
and pull this image it's gonna take a
few minutes depending on your
internet connection speed it's kind of a
large file that has to be downloaded so
we'll just wait for that to download
you can see the others have completed
just waiting for this last file to
download
almost there once that's done what we're
going to go ahead and
do is we'll actually uh run the docking
container and
create a new container using the image
that we just downloaded but we have to
wait for this to download first
all right so the image has been pulled
from docker hub and let's go ahead and
create the
new docker container so we're going to
do sudo docker
run dash d
dash p 0.0.0.0
colon 80 colon 80
and then put in my sql colon
latest so we have the latest version
and we have our new token and that shows
our new docker container has been
created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do sudo docker
ps to list all the
running containers and what we see is
that the container is not listed there
which means it's probably not running so
let's go ahead and list out all of the
images that we have
within docker so we can see whether it's
actually listed there so we'll do
ps-a and yes there we are we can see
that we do
have our new container my sql latest
and it was created 36 seconds ago but
it's in the exit
mode so what we have to do is we have to
change that
status so it's actually running
so let's change that to running state
we'll do sudo
docker
run dash
i t dash dash
name and we can name it
excel sql
my sql
slash spin slash flash
and that's now going to be in the route
and we'll exit out of that and now
if we list out the docking containers we
should see it
is now an active container
pseudo docker start
and then we'll start the scene and then
and we should now see it
there we are it's now in the running
state excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
clear the screen
okay now what we want to do is remove
the docker container
so we're to do is check list of images
that we have
and to pseudo docker images
here are the images that we have and we
have my sql is listed
and what we want to do is delete my sql
and to do that we're going to type in
sudo docker rm-f
image mysql
run that command and what we'll find is
the image there's no such image oh okay
so what we actually have to do is we
have to go and see
that the image is now gone it's been
removed
excellent exactly what we wanted to see
and we can also delete an image by its
image id
as well
however if an image is running and
active we have to
kill that image first so we'll go ahead
and we're going to select
the image id we'll copy that
and it's going to replace that
it won't be able to actually run
correctly because
the image is active so what we have to
do now is
stop the image and then we can kill it
so it's in the running state so
we have to do
so we do sudo darker kill
and kill sl and that will kill the
container
and now we'll see that the container has
gone
and now we can delete the image and
that's going to be the image going with
image id
but easy peasy okay let's go ahead on to
the next exercise which is to
well so here we are we've listed all of
the uh
containers and they're all gone so let's
go into the next exercise final exercise
which is to actually
create a batch image and we're going to
do a batch http image
so let's go ahead and write that out so
it's going to be
docker run
dash did dash dash
name
white which that's going to be the name
of
this http service dash p
8080 colon 80 dash v
open quotes dollar sign
pwd close quotes
colon slash usr
slash local slash
apache2 slash htdocs
slash httpd semicolon 2.4
we'll run that put in our password again
uh so what we see is the port is already
being used so let's go ahead and see
which ports
let's go see if we can change the port
or see what
ports are running so let's do sudo
images
and see which ports are being used
because
it's either the the port or the name
hasn't been put in correctly so
sudo docker images ps
sudo docker ps ps-a
and yep let's port 80 there
so we clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name because i think we actually have
the wrong container name here
so let's go and change that and we'll
paste that in and
voila there we go now
working and we'll just double check and
make sure everything's working correctly
so to do that we'll go into our web
browser
and we'll type in as soon as firefox
opens up
type in localhost
colon 8080
which was the the port that we created
and there we are it's a list of all the
files which shows that the server
is up and running today we're going to
cover what is a docker container
why you would want to consider using it
in your devops environment
so let's have a look at what we have in
our current environment so today
when you actually have your standard
machine you have the infrastructure you
have the host operating system
and you have your applications and then
when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually
creating virtual machines but those
virtual machines actually
are now sitting within a hypervisor
solution that sits still
on top of your host operating system and
infrastructure
and with a docker engine what we're able
to do is we're able to actually reduce
significantly
the different elements that you would
normally have
within a virtualized environment so
we're able to get rid of the the bins
and the
so we're able to get rid of the guest os
and we're able to eliminate the
hypervisor
environment and this is really important
as we actually start working
and creating environments that are
consistent because we want to be able to
make it so it's really easy
and stable for the environment that you
have within your
dev and ops environment now critical is
getting rid of that hypervisor element
it's just a lot of overhead so let's
have a look
at a container as an example so here we
actually have
a couple of examples on the right hand
side we have different containers we
have
one containers running apache tomcat in
a with java
my second container is running sql
server and microsoft.net environment
the third container is running python
with mysql these are all
running just fine within the docker
engine and sitting on top of a host os
which could be linux it really could be
any host os
within a consistent infrastructure and
you're able to
have a solution that can be shared
easily amongst your teams
so let's have a look at an example that
you'd have today if a company is doing a
traditional
java application so you have your
developers working in jboss
on his system and he's coding away and
he has to get that
code over to a test and now what will
happen is that tester will then
typically in your traditional
environment then have to install jboss
on their machine and get everything
running and cool
and hopefully set up identically to the
developer chances are they probably
won't have it exactly the same
but they're trying to get as close as
possible and then at some point you want
to be able to
test this within your production
environment so you send it over to a
system administrator who would then
also have to install jboss on their
environment
as well yeah this just seems to be a
whole lot of duplication so why go
through the
problem of installing jboss three times
and this is where it things get really
interesting because the challenge you
have today
is that it's very difficult to almost
impossible to have identical environment
if you're just installing software
locally on devices the developers
probably got a whole bunch of
development software that could be
conflicting with the jboss environment
the tester has similar testing software
but probably doesn't have all the
development software
and certainly the system administrator
won't have all the tools that the
developer and tesla have their own tools
and so what you want to be able to do is
kind of get away from the challenge you
have
of having to do local installations on
three different computers
and in addition what you see is that
this uses up a lot of effort because
when you're having to install software
over and over again you just keep
repeating doing really basic
foundational challenges
so this is where docker comes in and
docker is the tool that allows you to be
able to share environments from
one group to another group without
having to
install software locally on a device you
install
all of the code into your docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what docker actually is
and then we're going to dig into the
actual architecture of docker and
kind of go through what docker container
is and how to create a docker container
and then we'll go out through the
benefits of using docker containers
and then the commands and finalize
everything out with a brief demo
so what is docker so docker is
as you'd expect because all the software
that we cover in this series
is an open source solution and it is a
container solution that allows you to be
able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run
the solution you're building so you can
share it from
different people in your team whether
it's a developer a tester or system
administrator
and this allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into that
architecture so you understand
why docker runs effectively so the
docker architecture itself is built up
of two key elements there is the docker
client
and then there is a rest api connection
to a docker daemon which actually
hosts the entire environment within the
docker host
and the docker demon you have your
different containers and each one has
a link to a docker registry the docker
client itself
is a rest service so as you'd expect a
rest api
and that sends command line to the
docker daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window
and we'll go through some of these demos
later on so you can actually see how you
can actually interact with darker
the docker demo then checks the request
against and the
docket components and then performs the
service that you're requesting
now the docker image itself all it
really is a collection of instructions
used to create a container
and again this is consistent with all
the devops tools that we have
the devops tools that we're looking to
use throughout this series of
videos are all environments that can be
scripted and this is really important
because it allows you to be able to
duplicate
and scale the environments that you want
to be able to build very quickly and
effectively
the actual container itself has all of
the
applications and the dependencies of
those applications in one
package you can kind of think of it as a
really
effective and efficient zip file it's a
little bit more than that
but it's one file that actually has
everything you need to be able to run
all of your solutions the actual docker
registry itself is an environment for
being able to host and distribute
different docker images among your team
so say for instance you had
a team of developers that were working
on multiple different
solutions so say you have a team of
developers and you have 50 developers
and they're working on five different
applications
you can actually have the applications
themselves the containers
shared in the docker registry so each of
those teams
at any time check out and have the
latest container
of that latest image of the code that
you're working on
so let's dig into what actually is in a
container
so the important part of a docking
container
is that it has everything you need to be
able to run the application it's like a
virtualized environment
it has all your frameworks and your
libraries and it allows the teams to be
able to build out
and run exactly the right environment
that the developer intended what's
interesting though is the actual
applications then
will run in isolation so they're not
impacting other applications
that's using dependencies on other
libraries or files outside of the
container
because of the architecture it really
uses a lot less space
and because it's using less space it's a
much more lightweight
architecture so the files the actual
folder itself
is much smaller it's very secure highly
portable
and the boot up time is incredibly fast
so let's actually get into how you would
actually create a docker container
so the docker container itself is
actually built through command line
and it's built of a file and docker
image
so the actual docker file is a text file
that contains all the instructions that
you would need to be able to create that
docker image
and then we'll actually then create all
of the project code with
inside of that image then the image
becomes the item that you would share
through the docker registry you would
then use the command line and we'll do
this later on
select docker run and then the name of
the image
to be able to easily and effectively run
that image
locally and again once you've created
the dock image you can store that in the
docker registry making it available to
anybody
within your network so something to bear
in mind is that
docker itself has its own registry
called docker hub and that is a public
registry so you can actually go
out and see other dock images that have
been created and access those images
as your own company you may want to have
your own private
repository so you want to be able to go
ahead and either do that
locally through your own repository or
you can actually
get a licensed version of docker hub
where you can actually
then share those files now something
that's also very interesting to know
is that you can have multiple versions
of a docker image so if you
have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test
and write code for those different
release versions because you may have
different setups
you can certainly do that within your
docker registry environment
okay so let's go ahead and we're going
to create a docker image using some of
our basic docker commands
and so there are essentially really you
know kind of just two commands that
you're going to be looking for one is
the build command another one is to
actually put it into your registry which
is a push command
so if you want to get a image from a
docker registry then you want to use the
pull command and
a pull command simply pulls the image
from the registry and in this example
using
nginx as our registry and we can
actually then pull the image
down to our test environment on our
local machine so we're actually running
the container within
our docker application on our local
machine we're able to then
have the image run exactly as it would
in production and then you can actually
use the
run command to actually use the docker
image on your local machine
so just a you know a few uh interesting
tidbits about
the docking container once the container
is created a new layer is formed on top
of the
docker image layers called the container
layout each container has a separate
read write container layer and any
changes made in that docking container
is then reflected upon the particular
container layer
and if you want to delete the container
layer the container layer also
gets deleted as well so you know why
would
using docker and containers be of
benefit
to you well you know some of the things
that are useful is that containers have
no
external dependencies for the
applications they run once you actually
have the container
running locally it has everything it
needs to be able to run the application
so there's no
having to install additional pieces of
software such as the example we gave
with jboss at the beginning of the
presentation
now the containers are really
lightweight so it makes it very easy to
share the containers amongst your teams
whether it's a developer whether it's a
tester whether
it's somebody on your operations
environment it's really easy to share
those containers amongst your entire
team different
data volumes can be easily reused and
shared
among multiple containers and again this
is another big benefit and this
is a reflection of the lightweight
nature of your containers
the container itself also runs in
isolation
which means that it is not impacted by
any dependencies you may have on
your own local environment so it's a
completely sandboxed environment
so some of the questions you might ask
us you know can you run
multiple containers together without the
need to start
each one individually and you know what
yes you can with
docker compose docking compose allows
you to run
multiple containers in a single service
and again this is a reflection on the
lightweight nature
of containers within the docker
environment so we're going to end our
presentation
by looking at some of the basic
commands that you'd have within docker
so
we have here on the left hand side we
have a docker container and then the
command
for each item we're actually going to go
ahead and use some of these commands
and the demo that we're going to do
after this presentation you'll see that
in a moment
but just you know some of the basic
commands we have are committing the
docket image
into the container kill is a you know
standard kill command to you know
terminate one or more of the
running containers so they stopped
working then restart those
containers but suddenly you can look at
all the image all of the commands here
and try them out for yourself so we're
to go ahead and start a demo of how to
use the basic commands to run
docker so to do this we're going to open
up terminal window or command line
deploying whether you're running linux
pc or mac
and we're going to go ahead and the
first thing we want to do is see what
our docker
image lists are so we can go sudo docker
images and this will give us
well first we'll enter in our password
so let's go enter that in
and this one that gives a list of our
docker images and
here are the doc images that have
already been created in the system
and we can actually go ahead and
actually see the processes that are
actually running so i'm going to go
ahead and
open up this window a little bit more
but this will show you the actual
processors and the containers that we
actually have and so
on the far left hand side you see under
names we have learn simply learn
be underscore cool these are all just
different ones that we've been
working on so let's go ahead and create
a docker image
so i'm gonna do sudo darker
run dash d
dash p 0.0.0.0
go on 80 colon 80.
ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run
an ubuntu image and this will run the
latest image and what we have here is a
hash number and this hash number is a
unique name
that defines the container that we've
just created
and we can go ahead and we can check to
make sure that the container actually
is present so we're going to do
sudo docker.ps and this actually shows
some there so it's not
in a running state right now but that
doesn't mean that we don't have it
so let's list out all the containers
that are both running and in the exit
state so let's do
sucker ps dash a and
this lists all the containers that i
have running on my machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running state and in the
exit stage
and here we see one that we just created
about a minute ago
and it's called learn
and these are all running ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and there we go
so let's change that to that new dock
container to a running state so scroll
down
and we're going to type sudo
docker
run dash i t
dash dash name
my um
so this is gonna be the new container
name it's gonna be my
docker so this is how we name our docker
environment and we'll
put in the image name which is ubuntu
and bin dash bash
and it's now in our root and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my docker container so sudo
docker
start my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker return
and that started that docker image and
let's go ahead and check against the
other running docker images to make sure
it's running correctly so
sudo docker ps
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side
you actually see my docker along with
the other docker images that we created
and it's been running for 13 seconds
quite fast
so we want to rename the container let's
use the command sudo
docker rename
we can take another docker image this is
grab this one and we'll put it in
rename and we'll rename and put in the
old container name which is image
and then we'll put in the new container
name and let's call it
purple so now the
container image that had proved to be
called image is now called purple
so we do sudo docker ps
to list all of our docker images
and we scroll up and there there we go
purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop containers so we're
going to write sudo
docker stop
and then we have to put in the container
name
and we'll put in my docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and
what you see is that it's not listed in
the active images
it's uh not on the list on the far right
hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still
there as an image is just not in an
active stage it's what's known as in an
exit state
so here we go
and there's my ducker it's in an exit
state so
that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
rm will remove
my docker and that will remove it from
the exit state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and yep
yep it's not not listed there under exit
state anymore
it's gone
and there we go there that's where it
used to be
all right let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo
kill and then the name of the container
i think one of them is called yellow
let's just check
and see if that's gonna kill it
oops no i guess we don't have one called
yo so let's find out name of the
container that we actually have
so pseudo docker kill
oh we're gonna list out the ones that
are running oh okay there we go now
yellow isn't in that list so let's
take i know let's take simply learn and
so we can actually go ahead and let's
write sudo docker
kill simply learn and that will actually
kill
an active docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now that
they simply learn container is not
active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
docker container
today we're going to dig into docker
swarm
so what we're going to do in this
session is we're going to go through
what a docker and docker container is
and why you'd want to use it
we'll then break out what are the
characteristics and structure of a
docker swarm environment
and then finally we'll go through and do
a demo using actual code in the command
line
interface to actually run and build out
the main
functions and commands that you would
use for
a docker swarm environment so with that
said
let's get started so docker is a tool
that we actually use to help automate
applications in our environment so that
we have a consistent way that we're
actually building and testing
and validating codes that's been created
think of it as a virtualization but much
more sophisticated and efficient way
of doing virtualization the thing that
you have that's
a huge advantage when you're working
with docker is that it's a very
lightweight
software package it allows you to have
all of the tools needed for actually
running the code
without having to have the significant
overhead that you would normally have
with virtualization
so one of the characteristics you have
with docker is that you can
actually run multiple docker
environments in the same host
environment
and for you to be able to do this we had
to figure out how this would actually
run and so to actually do this we
actually do what's called a docker swarm
and a docker swarm
is an environment where you can actually
have multiple docker images
running on the same host operating
system so you can have running in each
of those
docker containers different solutions
so let's dig into what a docker swarm is
so a docker swarm is essentially a tool
that allows you to very easily
create and schedule multiple docker
nodes so really
two or more docker nodes and you can
have quite a large number of
docker nodes in a single swarm uh each
node
itself is actually a docker daemon and
that demon is able to interact with the
docker api and have all the benefits
of being a full doctor environment
one of the other advantages you have is
that the
each doc container within the swarm can
then be deployed and managed but as a
node
in that entire clustered environment so
what we have here
is a breakdown of the five key elements
within
a docker environment you have the docker
container
you have the daemon the docker images
and the docker client and docker
registry
so the docker game itself is what does
all the work interacting with
the actual host operating system to be
able to manage the docker containers
so if we look here here we have set up
an environment where we have three
docket containers being run with
docker and what we want to be able to do
is it be able to interact with the
environment because what would happen
if we actually have something change in
our environment so we have
the environment set up as a docker swarm
and one of our containers
fails what we're able to do is use the
swarm to be able to correct that failure
so the docker
swarm manager is able to come in and
reschedule containers
and as you would imagine the actual
swarm note has full backups and
full redundancy for any kind of failures
that would happen
and we would do all of this work through
command line interface
so let's go through some of the features
that you have within the actual docker
swarm itself
so a key feature for docker swarm is
that it is
fully decentralized which means that it
makes it very easy for
teams to be able to access and manage
the environment
as you would expect as well is that the
communication that happens between the
manager
and client nodes within the swarm is
highly
secure and of course this is really just
a fundamental that you should have for
any kind of solution
but it is good to know that docker swarm
has that built in
there is also auto load balancing within
your environment
you can actually script that into how
you write out and structure your swarm
environment
and that load balancing then also allows
you to
then convert that swarm environment into
a highly scalable
infrastructure and then rollback task
allows you to be able to roll back
environments to previous safe
environments so say something that does
get pushed out
and something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment
so each of the containers are pushed out
and
and are controlled using services and
they actually happen to be breast
services which make it very easy for you
to be able to integrate
within your environment and each of the
different services contains a group of
containers of the same
image now by having this structure it
allows you to be able to scale your
application
appropriate to the demands on your
service so if you
have a service that needs to have a
significantly larger number
of services for it to run you can
actually scale that
appropriately and they can be either geo
or demand based
one of the requirements for setting up a
docker swarm is you must have at least
one node deployed so the way that the
architecture is set up is that you have
a manager node and a client node and
there must be one of each
for the entire environment to be able to
work effectively
so you know here we are just jumping
ahead of sales a little bit we have two
types of nodes in the docker swan we
have the manager node
and we have the worker node which is the
client that does the actual
execution of the tasks the manager note
very similar to other systems that we've
talked about on simply learn
allows you to actually control and
manage the actual
tasks that are being executed by the
worker nodes
and the worker nodes as you can imagine
and then actually execute the
instructions
that the manager are sending out to it
so here we have a situation where we can
illustrate what would happen
with a manager node sending out commands
to different worker nodes
the manager is fully aware of the status
of the entire swarm environment at all
times
this is because of the two-way secure
communication that's going from the
manager
to the worker environment the workers as
you'd expect are accepting tasks
that are being sent from the manager so
the manager sends out a task saying that
you need to be running
as a my sql environment then the worker
node will then convert to
my sequel environment and all of these
environments are scripted and controlled
by
you as the manager the actual worker
nodes themselves actually have a client
agent and that client will then
communicate all different states
of the infrastructure back to the
manager so that
any time the manager node is in full
control
of the entire swarm the manager is the
controller of this environment and so
you always want to be able to ensure
that the manager has full access to all
the work that's happening within the
swarm
and this allows you as the manager to be
able to control
your swarm and very quickly be able to
react to any changes without having to
rely on manual installations of software
and hardware
and as we covered earlier on there is a
rest api
that uses the communication over http
from the manager to the worker node it's
interesting to note that it is a rest
api
because if you wanted to you could
actually integrate that api
into custom applications and even then
create automated docker images to be
created
on demand from third-party solutions
that you may want to create
so one of the things that's a really a
big advantage with having a swarm is
that
once you've actually created the swarm
any of the services um that you create
can be accessed by
any node of the same cluster one of
things you do have to do though is you
have to specify
what container image that you're going
to use when you're creating
a new service and you can do that either
through a centralized
docker hub environment or through your
own private docker hub environment
one of the things that's interesting is
that you can set up commands and
services to be either global or
replicated a global service will
allow you to run a service consistently
on every
node within the swarm whereas a
replicated service
will only push out functionality
and tasks to specific worker nodes
within a swarm
so you may be asking yourself hey isn't
a service and task the same thing
no they're kind of not in the docker
world and the difference is is a service
is a description of a task for the state
whereas the actual task is the work that
needs to get
done and that's the differentiator here
so what you can do as a docker user is
you actually create
services and then you can then define
when you want them to start as
tasks now what's interesting is that
when you do assign a task to a node
that same task cannot be assigned to
another node
also what's interesting is that you can
actually have multiple managers
within a docker swarm environment if you
do however go down this path
you have to elect one manager to be the
primary manager
and the other managers to be secondary
managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really similar in
concept to
worker nodes in which they have the
capability of a manager but they are
dependent on
that single primary manager to be able
to provide the right instructions
and for services and tasks to the entire
swarm environment
so if we kind of recap some of these we
have a command line interface which
allows us to
create and connect via apis and that
those apis that we connect to in our
small environment
allows us to do orchestration via tasks
and services
the task allocation allows us to
allocate
work to tasks via their ip address
which allows them to execute them on the
work and then the worker nodes
themselves have to connect to the
manager node to be able to check for
when to ask them in
so that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm
and then the final stage is to actually
execute the tasks that have been
assigned from the manager node
to the work note so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build
all right so with that said let's go
ahead and we're gonna do
a demo so we're gonna go ahead and do a
demo and showing how you can run
docker swarm for this you'll need to
have both a virtual environment running
your manager
and your working environment so here we
have our worker
and here we have our manager so we're
just going to open up terminal window
and we're going to go into the manager
for terminal window
so the following command here is used to
initialize docker swan which is going to
type this
in so sudo docker swarm init
and we push the ip address for the
network we're connecting to
and we'll put in our password
and here we have now connected and this
is our manager node
and what we want to be able to highlight
is the specific token
which identifies the docker swarm
environment and this is our token right
here so we're going to copy that
because we'll need to use that for our
worker environment so
here we are in the work environment and
we'll use
the token that we just copied um as a
way to be able to connect to the manager
and connect
to the docker swarm environment
and so sudo
i'll paste in the docker swamp and we'll
join that
and now here we shows that we have
joined
the swarm environment as a worker
and now we're in the manager we can
actually show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's docker node ls
to list out all of the
items in that environment
sorry we actually did that in the wrong
area so we're on the right sudo docker
node
ls to list out all the nodes in the
swarm and there you are you see we've
actually connected the
worker to the manager node and both
are active and the manager is the leader
and the work of virtualbox
is in the swarm
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so docker swan create
and we're going to just change the name
to hello world for the new service and
we use the alpine
image from docker.com it takes just a
moment for it to run
there we go and there we go
services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new hello world
service
i'm going to go ahead and check the duck
and containers and we're going to do
docker ps and here's our
alpine it's running the latest image
and that's the docker container id
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node
and make sure everything is working over
there
so go over to our worker paste that in
so what we see here is there is no image
or container created because
it's not in the working node it would be
in the manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we'll make the mode global and that
way the service is available
across all of the swamp
so we're just going to execute that work
takes a moment
and
there we are done work has been
completed
and we have the two different ids which
shows that two different services
running and if we go back to the worker
mode
and we run sudo docker ps again and
there we are now we see that we have
the hello world new virtual environment
has been added with the image of
alpine and we also have the new token id
for that
if we want to kill a node from the swamp
we can use the following command which
is pseudo
docker swamp leave dash dash force
and that will force the node to leave
the swarm
today we're going to cover dhaka compose
so
in this session what we're going to do
is we're going to go through what docker
is and then by extension what docker
compose is and how
it improves the performance of docker
what the benefits of working with docker
compose
is we are going to cover as well what
the difference between docker compose
and docker swarm is because the two
products are similar but they have two
different types of job and at the end of
this presentation we'll take you through
some basic commands that allow you to
get up and running working with docker
and docker compose
finally after this presentation we'll do
a brief demo that allows you to get up
and running using some of these commands
to do your own docker compose
environment so let's get started with
docker compose
so first of all we have to kind of cover
what docker is so
docker has come as an evolution of
technologies that started with virtual
machines vm machines
and a vm machine allows you to run a
complete operating system and complete
operating system and its environment on
your
own computer in your own operating
system without it interfering
the problem was is that it's very heavy
and complex and in contrast
docker is a much more lightweight and
more flexible environment that you can
automate with scripts so we have to
remember that the container itself
is just software and it has dependencies
that run within that application
that are managed by docker so we have a
look at the way docker is broken out
first of all we have the docker image
and
we have the docker image created by a
docker file
and the docker file is a text-based
script
and that text file within dockerfile
actually has all the commands that allow
you to run the appropriate
technologies within the docker image so
the docker image allows you to be able
to
have a wide group of people and
consistently
run the same environment and if you want
to be able to share that docker image
effectively you would do so by uploading
to docker hub
and docker hub can be available either
publicly uh through the
the public docker hub website or you can
actually set up your own
private enterprise docker hub to share
your own images across your own network
and then from docker hub people
can then pull their own docker image and
build new containers that are consistent
on the original docker container that
you created so it's a great way of being
able to have your entire team
scale up easily and effectively so one
of the questions that will come up
though is
what if you want to use two containers
in a single service
and an example this might be like a web
server
that is using a database but the
database may be in one container and the
web server
may be in another container which is
very typical for your own
web and database infrastructure so very
similar
um scenario but how would you do this
with doc app so by using just docker
itself it's actually very difficult to
do
this you can do it but it's just very
time consuming
and just not a very good use of your
productivity but with docker compose you
can actually do the whole process
quite quickly and easily and hence the
reason why we have docker compose
to allow you to have two or more docker
containers
running in the same environment being
able to communicate as if they were
running in a production environment so
let's dig into
what docker compose is so let's consider
a
scenario that you'd have today so mintra
is a fashion website similar to
amazon and you'd go to intro with your
web browser
and on that website you would go through
a number of activities such as logging
into your account
browsing a catalog you'd have your
checkout
application server and you go through
the typical
process of building out an application
behind
each of these services are different
products such as you know to have an
account database you'd have a product
database
different checkout processes and these
would all be run
behind the scenes and each of these can
be considered
a micro service so the more
microservices you build into your
environment the more complexity you're
adding
and the more of value it would be to
have each of these services
in their own container but as a
developer you want to be able to jump
from one container to
another container so your login account
can then be passed on to your product
catalog
and then be able to move through the
whole process
so the environment that you would see
today would be small like what we're
showing right now where you'd have your
server and your database and you may
have a server running on apache tomcat
or a sql server you'd have different
databases and you'd want to be able to
have each of those in their own
containerized environment so the way
that duck compose
runs is that it works as a single
service so you have the docker compose
running multiple containers but the
perception is of a single service run
the thing that's great though is that
each of those containers will run in
their in isolation
and but they can interact with each
other so unlike a
normal docker environment where you have
multiple docker images running
completely in isolation
of each other these are images that will
run in isolation but can
interact with each other the docker
compose files are very easy to write
they're all written with
a scripting language called yaml and
yaml is an xml based language
it actually stands for yet another
markup language but it's an xml based
language
and it's very easy to use the great
thing about learning yaml is that a lot
of open source
tools in the devops environment use yaml
as the scripting link and then finally
in docket compose
as a user you can actually go and and
trigger
all your services within the containers
to start with a single command as you
can imagine this
dramatically reduces the amount of work
that you
as a developer have to do so let's take
an example
of if you're running a container one
with a ninjx
server and one with the redis database
uh you can create a
yaml docker compose file that actually
has the instructions on
the containers needed to build out both
environments
and then you can run each of those
environments separately but have them
connected as a single service so the
benefits of duck and compose is that you
have a single host
deployment environment you can run this
all on one piece of hardware
you can have a quick and easy
configuration using yaml scripts
the productivity that you get as a
developer significantly
increases because you're not having to
have time wasted
trying to configure just traditional
docker containers by themselves you now
have a way of being able to interact
with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of
all of these containers so each of those
containers
are completely isolated from each other
and they are controlled with the same
level security
that you'd have with a traditional
docker image but
there is a question here around docket
compose isn't it similar in concept
to docker swarm because at a high level
it kind of seems like
both do the same thing and the answer is
well actually no they're different there
are similarities but there are also
differences
and particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
solutions so let's look at docker
compose
so docker compose will allow you to
create multiple containers on a single
host and that's the important part
having a single host which is maybe your
development pc
with docker swarm it also allows you to
create multiple containers
however you have to manage those
multiple containers on
multiple hosts which makes a lot of
sense if you are running an operations
environment but
not so much if you're doing a
development environment
and docker compose is scripted with yaml
which is
very easy for you to be able to control
your scripts docker swarm
doesn't have a scripting technology like
yaml so it's a little bit harder to work
with so what we have here
is just some basic commands that allow
you to
get up and started working with docker
compose
in our next demo we're going to take you
through how to use all of those commands
so we're going to go ahead and do a demo
on how to use docker compose
um the first thing you want to do is
check that you have
docker installed so what we're going to
do is we're going to open up the command
window and we're going to type in
docker you'll be able to see now that we
have
docker installed uh if you don't have
dock installed go ahead and install
docker you can go to google search to
install docker and they'll give you the
instructions for that we also have
videos that we've already done
if once you have docker installed then
you want to do a google search on
docker compose or go to the docker.com
website
and select for the compose section and
look for the install docker compose
instructions so we already have another
tab which has
the instructions already installed
you'll see on the left hand side there
are a number of docker tools
you want to expand the docker compose
section select install
compose and then on the right hand side
you'll have different
install options for mac windows and
linux uh if you're installing
on those platforms make sure you copy
the correct command line so there's a
couple of command lines you want to
copy copy the first one over and we
paste that in and it's going to go ahead
and download
all of the files for compose it takes a
while but
uh we have to get another file so
while it's downloading we'll go get the
other command line just go back and grab
it real quick it was a little faster but
we'll copy that over there was a second
command
instruction and post that command yep
there's the command right there
and that will apply the appropriate
binary and once you've done that you can
actually go ahead and validate that you
have the correct version of docker
compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
docker dash
compose space dash dash version and
that will then give you a version build
once you know that you have
a version built that means that you have
everything installed correctly
on your machine so you can see here that
we have a version number which means we
have everything installed
you might see a different version number
depending on how old the video is when
you're watching it but we're using real
content at the moment and just go ahead
and clear the screen and now what we're
going to do
is create a folder where we're actually
going to install
the ammo file that will have the
instructions for our docker component
environment so
we're moving the cursor to the desktop
and on the desktop we're going to create
a new folder
and using the mkdirf command and we'll
call this one docker compose
f for file and then we'll move the
cursor into that new folder by using cd
command
and now we are in the folder called
docker compose f
and you can go look at your desktop and
you'll see it's there and now you want
to
select um pound touch docker dash
compose compose.yml and they'll actually
create
the new uh yaml file for you and you can
use the ls list
command ls docker dash compose.yaml and
they'll allow you actually now to step
in
and edit that file so let's go ahead and
hit return and that will allow us to go
in and edit the file
so now i'm in the editor and i'm going
to
write some instructions um so i'm i'm
going to put a couple mistakes in these
instructions so we can see how dr pose
catches those mistakes um so but most
this is going to be
fairly correct so you can just type this
out so we're going to start with
surfaces colon and we'll do web colon
and then we'll create image colon and
we'll do
a negix and then we'll do a database
colon
and we call the image redis and so what
you can see
because we have two reference images
we're actually calling
two different images two different
containers that will be created by
docker hub
uh so what we're gonna do is uh where we
can actually show you
um how that's pulling in you can go to
docker hub and you can actually
see the references to the images that
we've just created so go to docker hub
which is hall
hub.dr and you'll see
that and nigex redis those
are the default names for the images so
you could
do other images like http for
apache web server if you wanted to there
are a lot of images in docker hub so
suddenly have a lot of fun
building uh tools from that environment
so we're going to save those files
um in the docker image which is going to
colon wq to
exit this screen save the text and let's
go and run
our yaml file and you'll see the two
different
error messages that will come up so we
can do cat
docker dash compose dot yml and here we
have a display
of the text that we just wrote and now
let's go check the validity
of the file that we just created so
we'll do docker dash compose
config and we should get an error
message and there we are error message
and the reason why
we have an error message is because the
spacing is not correct
in the yaml file itself so let's go to
the actual
yaml file that we created let's go
through and we're going to use
uh just the file finder and you'll
actually
open up the yaml file in your text
editor your favorite text editor and
here we have
um the code that created it and let's
use the correct spacing
so that everything is spaced out
appropriately
in the image and so this is the spacing
that you'd expect to see
a space a line between surfaces and the
first image and the first image
is a tab in and then it reference what
the image is
and let's go ahead and clear the screen
and we'll see whether or not we've got
that all
correct it click um this clear screen
and we're going to check that everything
is running correctly and we're seeing
we're still getting an
error message and the reason why we're
getting another error
is that there's still a config error
in this the actual yaml file so
one of things you have to do when you're
creating a yaml file for
docker composers you actually have to
have the appropriate
version uh number in there so what we
have to do is we have to go and find
which
is the appropriate version and there are
three major versions one two and three
depending on the
age of docker that you have installed on
your computer
uh so if you have the very latest
version of docker 18 and newer
you would put 3.7 as the version number
and what we're going to do is we're
going to just check on the version that
we have installed and so just clear the
screen
and then we'll just do docker version
and what we have is our version of
docker's
17.12 now this is the version of docker
not docker compose
uh it's your main docker environment and
so if we go back
to our web browser we'll actually see
that
version 17 should align
with version number 3.5 yep there we are
version 3.5 so what we want to do is go
back into our yaml file
the very first line that we want to put
in above the services
is the version number and that version
number we're going to put in
is 3.5 so we type in version version
and we put colon and then version number
is in
bright in quotes and you save that and
now
what we can actually do is we can
actually go ahead and use
the single line instruction to
run both of these uh two
images that we've created because
everything is configured correctly or
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way that
docker compose works
it pulls out the services and the images
that you'd create
and then put the image the version
number at the bottom
of the list so in the presentation we
talked about how
you can use one line to trigger two or
more
images and so to do that we're going to
do sudo
docker dash compose up dash d and it's
going to create
the two environments we have the web
environment and the database environment
and let's use sudo docker ps to actually
list
out that all the processes that are
running right now and there we are we
actually see
all of the images are running we have
the names the commands the
images and everything's up and running
and if we want to
close both of those images we can
actually
use a single line of command as well and
that command will be
sudo docker dash compose down
and that closes both of the images and
we can see that all the
databases and the web services images
have been closed
and sudo ps which it lists that there is
nothing running
and that's how to use docker compose so
let's get on to our next section which
is containerization
so let's go through and you're going to
be asked to explain what the
architecture of
docker is and docker really is the most
popular containerization environment so
docker uses a client server architecture
and the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line
and and then the docker daemon which is
run as a rest api
within the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and
run the docker containers and then the
docker
image is a template of instructions
which is used to create containers
the docker container is an executable
package of applications and its
dependencies together
and then finally the docker registry is
a service to host and distribute docker
images
among other users so you'll also be
asked to provide
what are the advantages of docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact um you may want to
even extend it as
having what are the differences between
having a dedicated machine a virtual
machine
and a docker or docker-like environment
and really the the arguments for docker
are just absolutely fantastic you know
first of all docker does contain and
occupy docket containers occupy
significantly less space than a virtual
machine or a dedicated machine
the boot up time on docker is
significantly
faster than a vm containers have a much
better performance as they are hosted in
a single docker image
docker is highly efficient and very easy
to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation
uh docker data volumes can be shared and
reused among
multiple containers the argument against
virtual machines is
significant and particularly if you're
going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't
moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your arguments for docker
are going to be very very persuasive
be very clear on what the advantages are
for docker
over a virtual machine because you want
to be able to succinctly share them with
your team
and this is something that's important
when you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they
aren't used to working with the tools
like docker you need to be able to
effectively
share with that team what the benefits
are so how do we share docker containers
with different
nodes and in this instance what you want
to be able to do is leverage the power
of docker swarm
so docker swarm is a tool which allows
the it administrators and developers to
create and manage
clusters of swarm nodes within the
darker platform
and there are two elements to the node
there's the manager node and then
there's the
the worker node the manager node as
you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of
the agent as it gets executed so what
are the commands to create a docker
swarm
and so here we have an example of what a
manager
node would look like and once you've
created a swarm on your magic node you
can now add worker nodes
to that swarm and again when you're
stepping through this process be very
precise in the execution part that needs
to be
taken to be able to effectively create a
swarm so start with the manager node and
then you create
a worker node and then finally when a
node is initialized as a manager node it
can immediately create
a token and that token is used for the
worker nodes and associating
the ip address with the worker nodes
question 17
how to run multiple containers using a
single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers a single service by using
docker compose
and docker compose will actually run
each of the
services in isolation so that they can
interact
with each other the language used to
write
out the compose files that allow you to
run
the service is called yaml and yaml
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a docker file
so dockerfile actually is used for
creating docker images
using the build command so let's go
through and show
on the screen what that would look like
and this would be an opportunity where
if you're actually in a technical
interview you could potentially even ask
hey
can i draw on a whiteboard and show you
what the architecture for using the
build command would look like and what
the process would look like um again
when you're going through an interview
process
as someone who interviews a lot of
people one of the things i really like
is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different
and in this instance this is a great
example of where you can stand up to the
whiteboard
and actually show what can actually be
done through actually creating images on
the whiteboard very quickly little
square boxes where you can actually
show the flow for creating a build
environment as an
architect this should be something that
you're comfortable doing
and by doing it in the interview and
suddenly you want to ask permission
before you actually do it
but doing this in the interview really
helps demonstrate your
comfortable feelings of working with
these kind of architecture drawings so
back to the question of creating a
docker file so we go through
and we have a docker file that actually
then goes ahead and creates the docker
image
which then in turns creates the docker
container and then we are able to push
that out
up to a docker hub and then share that
docker hub
with everybody else as part of the
docker registry with the whole
network so what are the differences
between docker image and docker
containers so let's go through the
docker
image so the docker images are templates
of a docker container
an image is built using a docker file
and it stores that docker file in a
docker
repository or a docker hub and you can
use docker hub as an example
and the image layer is a read-only file
system
the docker container is a collection of
the runtime instances of a docker image
and
the containers are created using docker
images and they are stored in the docker
daemon and
every container is a layer is a read
write
file system so you can't replace the
information
you can only append to it so while you
can actually use yaml
or writing your so a question you can be
asked is instead of yammer what can be
an
alternate file to build docker compose
so yaml is the one that
is the default but you can also use json
so if
you are comfortable working with json
and my
that is something that you should be uh
get comfortable with is
you want to be able to use that to name
your files and as a frame reference
json is a logical way of being able to
do value paired
matching using a javascript like syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a docker container so let's go
through what that would look
and we'll break it down task by task so
the task is going to be
create a mysql docker container so to do
that you want to be able to build
a docker image or pull from an existing
docker image from a
docker repository or hub and then you
want to be able to then use docker to
create a new container which has my
sequel from the existing docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is
also created on top of that image and
below at the bottom of the screen we
have what the commands lines look for
that
so what is the difference between a
registry and a repository so let's go
through that
so for the docker registry and
repository for the registry we have a
docker registry is an open source
server-side service used for hosting and
distributing docker images
whereas in contrast for repositories a
collection of multiple versions of a
docker image
in a registry a user can distinguish
between docker images with their tag
names and then finally on the registry
docker also has its own default retreat
called docker harb
for the repository it is a collection of
multiple versions of docker images it is
stored in a docker
registry and it has two types a public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own enterprise registry so
you're gonna be asked you know what are
the cloud platforms that
support docker really you know list them
all and we have listed here amazon web
services microsoft
azure google cloud rackspace but you
could add in their
ibm bluemix you could put in red hat
really any of the cloud service
providers out there today
do support docker it's just become an
industry standard
so what is the purpose of expose and
publish commands
in docker so if we go through expose
is an instruction used in dockerfile
whereas publish
is used in docker run command for expose
it is used to expose
ports within a docker network whereas
with publish it can be used outside of a
docker environment
for expose it is a documenting
instruction used at the time of building
an image
and running a container whereas with
published is used as to map
a host port to a running container port
for expose is it's the command
used in docker whereas for publish we
use the command-p
for when we're doing our command line
used in docker
and examples of these are expose 8080
or with docker we would put in or for
publish we'd do the example docker
run d dash p and then 0.0.0.80
a colon80 as our command line
with that we have reached the end of
this docker full course video
i hope you enjoyed this video do like
and share it
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simplylearn